so you're just back being successful as
usual if first of all have you gotten a
chance to take in the comic-con
craziness not this year
it just started yeah we got in last
night and we ate and this little bit
crazy this is my first year on a weekday
because I we had always been here on a
weekend on weekends I don't know about
your tomorrows when it gets blocked I
mean I saw people tell me stories so
listen when you read the description of
this show I have to be honest when show
business everything's a little weird
this might be the weirdest description
of a show of all time so Kevin can you
break these down we're gonna get scared
by Little Red Riding Hood well Little
Red Riding Hood's gonna scare you but oh
you mean the story will ya well it's
basically we've taken sort of the
classic fairy tales which are rather
grim if you go back before Disney and
and there's sort of we're taking
literally Riding Hood Hansel and Gretel
and the Three Little Pigs which these
two men are part of yeah and we're
intertwining them in a sort of a
10-episode drama that has a beginning
middle and end and we're taking the
themes and morals of all of the
storylines and subverting them into a
modern context I mean you sound so
eloquent when you explode I get it you
know why it's fine I was like three
little pigs this sounds how scary is is
gonna be on your scare levels it's you
know it's a drama so it has a lot of
dark undertones and there's a lot of
scary moments but it's a very dramatic
show is very emotional show it's you
know we're sort of sort of we're in the
cable space and we get to sort of play
with the characters and sort of unravel
them and show the bad guy becomes good
the good guy becomes bad you're not
quite sure what you're watching at any
given land they're real people you know
as opposed to they're not playing that
sort of a typical archetype yeah off the
big bad wolf they're actual people who
have you know it's it's not a heightened
fear it's not a heightened
special-effects it's it's very modern
it's very real it's very grounded and
it's a drama about real people but as
you're watching you'll go oh that's the
little pig
like that's the you have to soar no no
no it's an adult drama and I think
that's actually what's so cool guys I
think people at home I'm repeating what
you said but people are gonna be
watching it they're gonna be watching
this drama that has these and then
they're gonna go oh oh yeah then who is
the wolf his little Riding Hood the hero
of the story you know or zero wolf
lurking inside of her you know it's sort
of an which is the theme which is don't
stray from the path there's there's
strangers in the world though they'll
bill do bad things to you or you'll do
bad things to yourself Oh who's
responsible you were then now what's it
been like for you guys to team up again
I think were you yeah what was your name
listen just make it was fairly
abbreviated like I'm so flattered that
Kevin came to me with this because this
is the opposite of Stefan on the
vampires you know and just the fact that
he was able to sort of say hey okay I
want to give Paul crack at doing
something different and much more you
know I hate to say it but like a little
bits more sophisticated more mature in
that I'm not saying vampires was very
complex but it was a specific genre and
there's a specific audience type and
this is streaming and this is a
character who is he's not he's the
antihero in many senses he's he's down
on his luck derelict I hate to objectify
him but he's a guy who was like a
substance abuser and yeah Stefan was
this sort of the hero who's you know
sort of saving the world and and so it's
the opposite so the fact that you were
able to did you make him audition I know
I was so my answer is ditto in reverse
because I I was like would you be
willing to play this character and and I
actually sent him the script
earlier and just said you know read this
what do you think and you know because
we you know we've been in touch since
Vampire Diaries yeah and and we just
sort of always sort of been hanging out
and I just gave him the script and he
was like I love this I love this and
then when I said what about this role
because it's a certain specific role
it's sort of a character piece for him
and that's how I what I want to see Paul
do next and so I gave it to him and said
this is something I think you
kill okay no pressure did you have to
audition because I was ready to say
something else but no I didn't have to
audition but I was I was gonna say you
know like I I in a way you would think
my character Jordan could be the hero in
the story and then I remember I step
behind the monitor and I saw Paul
playing his character who's supposed to
be the bad guy and I was like oh you so
much hate those people are gonna really
like that bad guy haha he's the hero too
and I think that's how a lot of these
characters are is theirs they're so
human yeah and there's so much going on
for them that people are gonna identify
even if it's a bad person yeah you know
there's a reason why and I think that's
gonna be fun for the audience there's so
many rich characters in this what I'm
most concerned about are you know our
screens go to combust with both of your
faces on the screen because you're very
handsome I don't know if the computers
it's dreaming I'm telling it's they're
easier things than to sit with these
guys they wanted they're like heaven sit
in the middle is it because if they're
too close like the whole studio just
explodes it's like the old guy in the
money should say that because we can't
get a decent selfie to save our lives
you should see a compilation of us no no
no no we're all like I don't know I
don't know yeah it's true they're both I
mean the whole cast though is a
beautiful cast but I'm just like because
I've got the best of both worlds you
know I've got you know if you go and
look at the whole cast I didn't ever
plan for it to be so pretty and so I've
been roughing him up a little bit and
trying to dirty him out James playing
this part is you know what I think of
James is a sweet wholesome man and he
goes to a very very dark place and and
and it he he goes from being sweet and
nice really quick and you have someone
making a big TV return in your cast Kim
Cattrall how did you manage to convince
her to do this project well I you know
we we've just we sent the script to her
people and gave it to her I just assumed
it'd be an easy pass because we said
look we get it she's gonna say no she
says no to everything yeah
she's gonna say no to this yeah and then
next thing you know I got a phone call
going she wants to talk and I went oh oh
okay this is good this is good and she
and we started discussing we got on the
phone for an hour and then when I
finally met her like I was just sitting
in a room with her and I could yesterday
or day before yesterday and we were
discussing the role in them and she just
she's so into it and she wants to sort
of really you know she wants to play the
grandmother she wants to play though did
she was please let us play a character
she don't wanna play my own age and I
want to play this role and I want to
sort of have this and it's a wonderful
relationship between you know these two
women and and a young woman and Kim and
how they learn from each other and grow
and have an emotional bond and when that
gets ripped apart it's quite it's quite
um powerful and she's all in she's all
in I love that okay last thing I know
you guys got to go obviously you are in
the business of breaking the internet
because the Dawson's Creek cover the
reunion cover 40w I mean it was like the
world had it weird that's all we could
talk about for weeks so during that
shoot was there any talk about a
possible reunion of any kind oh I know
sorry Entertainment Tonight I need let's
just say there is talk there's talk
there's talk and it was because of
Entertainment Weekly
because wittiness all together yeah and
sort of reminding us of just how special
that time was and how much we loved each
other
yeah and there has been talk like Katie
Holmes website on top I'm not I can't
say anything okay I'm sworn to secrecy
there's a text chain with gifs it's a
Jeff or a gif I guess sure maybe it's a
joke I don't know it's my thing I would
say there's a lot of texting going on
there's contracts being signed it
currently no okay thank you so much for
coming so good to see you and
come on over there